[Music]
on this Thursday night Israel's 4-Hour
pause the new daily humanitarian window
for gazin trying to get out of Harm's
Way we're trying not to harm innocent
people yet civilian deaths increase as
Israel's Siege decimates the
territory the conflict's consequences in
Canada this is not an anti-semitic thing
it's a land thing the Montreal Clash is
sparked by the Middle East crisis and
the violent threats to schools plus
lights cameras back in action the pay
raise and new safeguards for actors as
Hollywood's historic strike
ends and from protection to expression I
wanted it to be something that wouldn't
necessarily remind me um of my time in
the military the Canadian veterans
moving forward by turning their
equipment into
art global national with Donna FZ
reporting tonight Faron Nasser good
evening thanks for joining us Israel has
begun a daily 4our military pause in
Gaza according to the White House Israel
will give a three-hour warning before
the pause to allow people to leave North
Gaza to South Gaza along humanitarian
corridors and to get more Aid to
civilians despite the renewed diplomatic
momentum the Israeli military stressed
its War continues Israel's primee
Minister says There Will will not be a
ceasefire until the hostages being held
by Hamas are released more than 10,800
people have died in Gaza that includes
more than 4,000 children according to
the Hamas run Health Ministry 1,400
people in southern Israel were killed on
the October 7th attacks and the IDF says
35 soldiers have been killed since the
ground Invasion US President Joe Biden
also told reporters today that he had
asked the Israelis for a pause longer
than 3 days during negotiations over the
release of some hostages un officials
are cautioning the conflict in Gaza
could expand with its Aid Chief warning
that allowing the situation there to
continue would be a travesty Mike
Armstrong has our top story from
Jerusalem and before that a warning some
of the details in it may be
[Music]
disturbing it is a road that dates back
basically as long as recorded history it
was used by the ancient Egyptians and
the armies of Alexander the great and
Napoleon the latest chapter in the story
of Salah alen road is refugees using it
to move South for the fifth day the
Israeli Defense Forces opened a corridor
through the land in Gaza they now
control the window Thursday open from
10:00 a.m. for 6 hours according to us
officials Israel has also agreed to open
a second Corridor along a coastal
Road bombs have been dropped from one
end of the Gaza Strip to the other
together but the bulk of them in the
north the IDF says about 50,000 people a
day have listened to the warnings and
left that isn't
easy this man says he tried to move
South but was with a group that came
under Fire from an Israeli
tank now the IDF took several foreign
journalists into Gaza Wednesday these
are images from what was a 90minut tour
to participate the Reuters crew that
took them had to agree to allow the isra
Army to review its material that crew
says everything it shot was approved in
the images the IDF shows off what it
says are two floors of workshops used to
make weapons located in a residential
building oer 7 came from here came from
houses like like
this in the South a region that may be
safer but certainly not safe and those
who have moved there struggle for
shelter medicine food and and
water now Israel has reached a deal with
the UN the US and Egypt on Aid trucks
are scanned and inspected before they're
allowed in the goal according to the US
is to get to a minimum of 150 trucks per
day if we will see that Hamas will use
the humanitarian Aid that comes from
nitana through
Rafa we will stop
it there was move movement at the Border
in the other direction Thursday foreign
citizens were again allowed to leave for
Egypt including 32
Canadians this woman says she suffered
through weeks of humiliation and feels
as though the world doesn't care about
the cries and pain of
Palestinians now this is video released
Thursday by a group holding some of the
Israeli hostages taken October 7th a
spokesman for the AL H's Brigade says
it's ready to release a woman because
she needs medical attention and a
teenage boy because of his age it says
it will let them go when the security
situation on the ground allows
it the Israeli military is calling the
video psychological warfare and says it
shows the group that released it is
under pressure and in
distress there may also be movement with
some of the hostages being held by Hamas
several political leaders from that
group are based in Cotter and there
reports both the CIA and Israeli
intelligence are in that country for
talks with qari mediators one of the
things being discussed would be the
release of 10 to 15 hostages in exchange
for a one or two day humanitarian pause
in fighting Farah Mike Armstrong in
Jerusalem for us tonight thank you Mike
18 people were killed and at least 20
others were injured in raids by Israeli
forces on the Janine refugee camp in the
West Bank this is according to
Palestinian Health
authorities Israel's military says it
was conducting counterterrorism raids
but it gave no further details local
officials say at least 178 Palestinians
have been killed in the West Bank since
the October 7th attacks on Southern
Israel the latest raid is the deadliest
since Israel's War began and that war
has the US on high alert in the Middle
East East for activity by iran-backed
groups Washington says it carried out
air strikes in eastern Syria yesterday
against a weapons Warehouse used by
Iran's Islamic revolutionary guard Corps
it is the second time in less than two
weeks the US has hit facilities in Syria
in response to attacks by Iranian
proxies on US forces in Iraq and in
Syria an unmanned American drone was
also shot off the coast of Yemen by
iran-backed houthi forces the group
released this video and they say it
shows the Drone being shot down by a
surfac to a
weapon there is concern in Montreal over
a rise in violent incidents connected to
the Israel Hamas War yesterday three
people were injured and one person was
arrested after an altercation at
Concordia University and overnight
police say two Jewish schools were hit
by gunshots prime minister Justin
Trudeau condemned the two incidents
saying there's no place for hate in
Canada
our diversity includes diversity of
perspectives and
opinions but not to
hate not to lash out with threats of
violence or actual violence against
someone you disagree
with Phil Carpenter now on what happened
and how the city's
reacting Montreal police spent much of
Thursday at two Jewish schools in
Montreal after responding to 911 calls
about bullet holes found on the front
entrances of the buildings in the city's
courot District the first one a call
that was made at around 820 for an
impact that was found by someone from
the school The Bullet Hole is in one of
the main doors of the United talmud
Torah Elementary School just 3 km away a
bullet hole was also found in the door
frame at the yiva gadola of Montreal
first information that were gathered on
those two events gunshots were fired
during the night so there was no one in
the school luckily so no one was injured
up until late afternoon Thursday police
say there were no suspects nor arrests
this incident has sparked fear that
tensions between supporters of Palestine
and Israel are rising in the city as the
Israel Hamas conflict intensifies
Montreal police say there has been an
increase in the number of hate incidents
targeting both Jewish and Muslim
communities people are asking questions
where is this going to lead Thursday's
shootings follow on altercation
Wednesday afternoon at Concord
University between two groups that led
to one arrest according to the
university swastikas were also found the
university denounced what happened in a
l to the school Community saying both
Jewish and Muslim members of our
community have reported provocative
comments insensitive or hostile social
media posts and expressed fear in courin
Thursday Jewish groups expressed concern
about their safety we've gone from
insults to harassment to Violent
harassment to actual violence police say
it's too soon to know if the shootings
were sparked by the tensions still
Community leaders are calling for come
we want to protect everyone in this
world we want to make sure that we live
in peace we are the most diverse
borrower of this city police say they
have stepped up Patrols in the areas
Phil Carpenter Global News
Montreal a major change to Canada's
labor code was announced today that will
affect almost 1 million federally
regulated workers the liberal government
tabled legislation Banning employers
from hiring replacement workers during
strikes now this was a core demand of
the new Democrats and their agreement to
support the minority liberals teria isri
reports we not done brother this has
been a year of Labor
Strife the most recent in Metro
Vancouver where Rogers Communications
locked out 300 unionized
technicians but new protections on the
picket line are coming today is indeed a
historic day for workers right across
this country labor Minister Sheamus oan
introduced legislation Banning employers
from hiring replacement workers during
lockouts and Strikes in Industries like
Transportation Banking and
Telecommunications employers who break
the rules will face fines of up to
$100,000 a day while the Liberals made
the announcement this was really a win
for the NDP they would have never tabled
this legislation but for the fact that
new Democrats and labor together fought
to make this
happen the new Democrats have tried to
make this happen over the past 15 years
their attempts were voted down by both
the conservatives and liberals the
difference this time the legislation was
a key demand and the NDP Supply and
confidence agreement needed to keep the
Liberals in power it was messy and and
difficult what we've done here I believe
is done something that's so important to
our economy right now and that is
provide more certainty and more
stability the Canadian Chamber of
Commerce warns it will have the opposite
effect what they will do is to encourage
more labor disruptions and longer
strikes as a result similar anti-cab
laws already exist in British Colombia
and Quebec this legislation is for those
generations of workers who have
courageously stood on a picket line in
Canada you have a piece of this Victory
but it won't be an immediate Victory
once the legislation passes it will take
at least 18 months before the anti-cab
laws come into effect that's how long
the tribunal that deals with complaints
says it will need to get ready for the
changes teria isri Global News
Ottawa the federal government's fall
economic statement will be presented
later this month and it's expected to
focus on housing and affordability today
prime minister Justin Trudeau announced
$900 million over four years to
accelerate housing Construction in
Quebec now it's money The Province will
match to help create tens of thousands
of new homes but as Mackenzie gray
reports other provinces aren't
happy it's the largest investment yet
from the liberal signature housing fund
when we put forward $900
million uh as Quebec's share of the
housing
accelerator the province of Quebec said
okay we're going to step up and double
it the combined $1.8 billion will build
more than 23,000 homes across Quebec
8,000 of which will be affordable units
I'm very happy to be able to have this
agreement to get that money France wo
had to agree to speed up the permitting
process and require increased density
but Quebec is the only Province to get
housing cash from Trudeau in the rest of
Canada the Liberals have cut deals
directly with cities leaving other
Premier peeved you can't have the
federal government going into a certain
town or a certain city and uh dumping
funding and not even discussing it with
the province that's that's unacceptable
what about other provinces
Justin the Prime Minister defending the
asymmetrical approach if people say oh
we want to be working as closely as the
government of Quebec is with uh the
government of Canada come on we're happy
to do that need to be focused on
regardless of who gets the money
homelessness experts want less
jurisdictional squabbling and more
building it doesn't really matter to us
but we need all three levels of
government working together it will be
at least 2 years before any of the
Quebec units are built but in that time
the Canadian mortgage and housing
Corporation says 45% of Canadian
mortgage holders will renew at a higher
rate costing an additional $15 billion
annually far McKenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks McKenzie the show will go on
coming up Hollywood actors wrap up an
historic
strike
thousands of passengers faced major
delays at Canada's largest airport today
after an apparent Mistake by a worker on
the
ground Toronto's Pearson airport says
the disruption was caused after a ground
Handler contracted by an airline
directed domestic passengers to an area
meant for screened us-bound passengers
several flights were delayed over a
2hour period one of the longest actor
strikes in Hollywood history appears to
be coming to an end the actor's Union
has agreed to a tentative deal with the
group representing Studios and streaming
services after months on the picket line
for many it's the fairy tale ending they
were hoping for but as Jackson prco
explains it may not be back to business
as
usual you get power you get power this
reaction was no performance oh my God we
did it thousands of Hollywood actors
found out their 118 day long strike is
over they can get back to work
immediately I think we've all been
waiting for this to happen for a long
time the lengthy labor dispute ended
with an agreement to pay actors more and
protect their jobs from future
technology like AI the big studios call
it a new paradigm that includes the
largest minimum wage increase in four
decades the overall valuation of these
contract gains is over a billion dollars
during the term of this contract that's
by far the largest set of gains we've
ever achieved in a contract negot
Association in Hollywood North it's a
huge relief thousands of workers were
sidelined as production of American
shows stopped hopefully this means a
swift return to production and and shows
coming back up here and people getting
back to work for all their big wins
actors are returning to work in a
rapidly changing industry it is probably
the case better paying jobs somewhat
more secure jobs but fewer of them
spending on content is going to be
slashed um the Legacy companies are not
all going to survive but the show must
go on the big studios are planning to
turn the lights back on as soon as
possible they face pressure from
audiences and broadcasters to crank out
new content quickly there's going to be
a log Jam everybody is going to be
fighting over these actors because we've
got six eight months of Productions that
all want to shoot at the same time after
four months on the picket line labor
peace may not last the powerful Union
representing film and TV Crews will see
its contracts expire next summer
potentially stealing the show Once Again
Jackson prco Global News
Washington Fast Car Tracy
Chapman a historic win at this year's
Country Music Awards as Tracy Chapman
becomes the first black songwriter to
win the CMA song of the year fastar was
first released in 1988 but researched in
popularity after country artist Luke
Colmes recorded a cover this year
Chapman says it's truly an honor for my
song to be newly recognized after 35
years still ah had the thick foam
covering sections of a sacred Indian
[Music]
River a toxic white foam is formed over
sections of New delhi's yamuna River as
the Indian Capital battles hazardous
pollution officials say it's caused by
sewage and Industrial Waste the city's
been blanketed by smog for a week
officials have shut down schools stopped
construction and imposed restrictions on
using vehicles to help improve air
quality there's now a proposal to create
rain through cloud seeding technology
later this month a new report says the
past 12 months have been the Earth's
hottest stretch on record
according to climate Central a nonprofit
science research group our planet's
average temperature was 1.32 de Celsius
above pre-industrial levels from
November of 2022 to this past October
and 90% of the world's population
experienced at least 10 days of abnormal
temperatures which were very strongly
affected by climate change according to
the report scientists also believe that
2023 will be the Earth's hottest year on
record with near certainty
[Music]
just bringing about molding new Futures
next the pottery project helping
veterans rekindle their
creativity for many veterans making
their transition out of service and into
civilian life can be challenging and
sometimes even isolating an NOA Scotia
artist is bringing them into her Pottery
Studio to connect them with their own
creativity and is pach reports it's in a
way that also honors their service so
that's just bringing it up right molding
clay into something new takes on a
deeper meaning for veterans at Lynette
Peters Pottery Studio I have such a love
and a respect for veterans and for what
they've done for us her husband served
in Afghanistan after he was released
from that service the co 19 pandemic
shut down the world so Peters came up
with a project using decommissioned
military helmets to help veterans the
helmets are a cradle for something
different they are so much more and they
can have so many purposes and so many
different things that they can fulfill
within their lifetime I used the
earpiece or the ear cup to form um this
piece here in the bowl and former
helicopter pilot Elona Inman used an
aviation helmet for her piece I chose
not to make the
piece shaped like the helmet because I
wanted it to be something that was
representative in an abstract sense that
wouldn't necessarily remind me um of my
time in the military because I'm not
there anymore glaze it all and then just
wait till it gets fired everyone makes
something different Navy veteran Chris
Hamilton's piece is reminiscent of the
real thing it just brings back a lot of
memories from my service and and what
this whole project kind of brings home
for me biggest memory is uh sailing with
a guy
um and him finding out we were on watch
when he found out his brother had been
killed in Afghanistan so that was
pretty pretty emotional Peters offers up
her studio and skills at no cost and
wants to inspire others to see veterans
differently how can we include veterans
how can we use our own skill sets to
include them and invite them along and
help them feel like they belong that is
I think our civic duty Peters has
already worked with more than two dozen
veterans transforming helmets like this
into pieces of art like this she has no
plans on stopping and hopes to hold a
public Art Exhibit someday the project
has a lasting impact on its participants
as you're rolling it out making your bit
there your memories are kind of going
into it capturing memories and molding
new Futures in clay Heidi pic Global
News East lawren toown novas scoia and
that's global national for this Thursday
night I'm far Naser tonight's your
Canada is the field of CR es in Calgary
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good
[Music]
night